le mot complexité ce mode qu'on ne
prononçait pas il ya à peine 50 ans ou
très peu aujourd'hui il est sur toutes
les lèvres est en fait la complexité
elle est là partout et entraîne pas mal
de stress est en fête
pour comprendre cette complexité comment
la générer comme en tout cas la gérer
l'étude du cerveau est intéressante
en deux mots un cerveau d'adultes 1400 g
100 milliards de neurones et un million
de milliards de connexions dans 1 kg 400
aujourd'hui la science permet petit à
petit de découvrir ceux qui à
l'intérieur du cerveau et comment ils
fonctionnent nos recherches à nous nous
ont poussés à comprendre les
comportements humains et en fait nous
prenons 5000 décisions par jour en
moyenne
on s'arrête au feu rouge on démarre au
feu vert et ses décisions se prennent à
travers quatre types de gouvernance la
première en fait c'est ce qu'on appelle
souvent le territoire reptilien mais qui
ont en fait l'hypothalamus
il a deux fonctions la première s'est
assurée la vie les instincts boire
manger dormir copuler tout ce qui permet
en fait à l'humain aux animaux en fait
de se reproduire et d'être deuxième face
aux prédateurs
c'est lui aussi qui en gens dans le
stress pour sauver sa peau par la fuite
la lutte une inhibition deuxième
gouvernance la gouvernance grégaire plus
simple c'est la notion de dominance
soumission ses skis dont les troupeaux
dans l'émeute permet en fait à chacun de
trouver sa place troisième gouvernance
la gouvernance d'émotionnel beaucoup
plus riche ce territoire là en fait en
magazine au fil des années
vos connaissances vos découvertes vous
savoir vos savoir-faire vos compétences
et en fait ils emmagasinent comme un
disque dur pour permettre en fait à
chacun de prendre des décisions très
rapide dans ce qui est connu dans ce
qu'il a l'habitude de faire et le
quatrième un quatrième gouvernance la
gouvernance adaptative localisées
principalement dans les réseaux
neuronaux du cortex préfrontal et ce
territoire et cette capacité que nous
avons de créer d'engendrer en fait de
d'aborder l'inconnu d'aborder ce qu'on
ne connaissait pas mais qui un jour ou
l'autre se présente à nous la nouveauté
la non maîtrise c'est un territoire
créateurs qui permet précisément de
s'adapter et d'être ou de construire une
forme de mea compétences c'est-à-dire
cette capacité de voir les choses de
plus haut
alors on va les voir de façon plus
intense
je vais maintenant divisée en fait cela
en deux modes mentaux nous avons deux
modes manteau un mode mentale
automatique qui permet de résoudre le
connu la mettrie tout ce qui est
maîtrisé et il a en fait des
caractéristiques ses décisions par
milliers que vous prenez tous les jours
se base sur la routine des habitudes
il est du tube persévérance est comme ça
il sait pas autrement intéressant
parfois d'être rigide en tout cas face
aux feux rouges
et il est également simplificateur c'est
le jugement c'est bon c'est mauvais
c'est blanc c'est noir tout cela se fait
dans ce mode automatique
il a des certitudes est forcément
puisqu'il a appris plein de choses et
donc la seule réalité c'est ce qu'il
connaît et il fait nourri par l'enpi rim
c'est à dire l'expérience et l'image
sociale c'est à dire le regard de
l'autre sur nous nous fait également
prendre souvent des décisions en
fonction de la culture familiale de la
culture d'entreprise
en fait on est sensible à tout ça
parfois
on a envie de prendre d'autres décisions
soyons en fait dans les convenances et
ce territoire ce mode est très utile
chaque jour nous l'utilisons des
milliers de fois et heureusement parce
qu'il est efficient il est efficace
toutefois face à l'inconnu face à la non
maîtrise il est nul et c'est là on fait
que nous avons besoin de passer de
l'autre côté c'est à dire de pouvoir
mettre en route ce mouvement ce mode
mentale adaptatif qui a les
caractéristiques suivantes totalement à
l'opposé du mode automatique et en même
temps très complémentaires premièrement
la curiosité et oui la curiosité n'est
dès la petite enfance je sais pas si
vous avez déjà observé des enfants d'un
an deux ans trois ans quatre ans cinq
ans six ans qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
goûtent ils essayent ils touchent à tout
ils veulent comprendre
et oui c'est un naturel qui est en nous
pourquoi le perdons nous parfois est en
fait la curiosité le pourquoi
pourquoi maman pourquoi papa à l'âge de
3 ans de 4 ans et
prenons un exemple il vous pose la
question même maman pourquoi la nuit à
et là vous pouvez répondre de trois
façons différentes
la première mon petit chou tu seras ça
plus tard c'est un peu difficile joue
plutôt avec des playmobil ok qu'est ce
que vous lui dites vous lui dites
retournes à ta routine et petit à petit
s'estompe le goût de la curiosité le
goût d'apprendre une deuxième façon de
dire époux de cette ville mon petit chou
à vous prenez un ballon vous preniez une
orange vous faites tourner laurent vous
expliquer en fait quoi mais qu'on fait
il ya le soleil la nuit et tout cela il
va le comprendre il va le stocker dans
son mode automatique avec une compétence
supplémentaire très chouette mais une
troisième façon de faire c'est lui dire
mon petit chou ah oui pourquoi la nuit
et toi qu'est ce que tu penses cela
et vous allez voir votre enfant faire
ceci lever les yeux au ciel et on fait
rentrer dans son imaginaire c'est
fabuleux vous lui permettez en fait de
grandir de faire grandir ce cortex
préfrontal qui est tout petit à la
naissance et qui va grandir
biologiquement jusqu'à l'âge de 25 30
ans mais c'est important parce que c'est
là que vous développer l'esprit critique
la créativité l'innovation
ensuite la souplesse la souplesse oui
pour savoir accepter des choses qui
parfois nous dérange mais c'est pas pour
ça qu'il faut se résigner et la
souplesse permet la sagesse et lorsqu'on
fait vous développer ses deux premières
capacité d'ouvrir notre esprit face à la
difficulté plutôt que de rester rigide
sur un mode opératoire standard en fait
de façon naturelle ou devient beaucoup
plus nuancée c'est pas blanc c'est pas
noir non il ya des inconvénients il ya
peut-être des avantages est en fait
phénomène de la relativité de la prise
de recul sur soi même et l'ensemble de
ce mécanisme
lorsqu'il est mis en route vous permet
d'avoir une réflexion logique
rationnelle intelligente le bon sens qui
permet aussi d'avoir une opinion
personnelle
et lorsqu'on voit ces deux modes bande
on pourrait se dire tiens lequel
j'utilise et bien rassurez vous utilisez
les deux ne soyez jamais curieux devant
un feu rouge vous êtes mort ok et
utilisez votre routine par contre
lorsque la chose est difficile lorsque
vous ne maîtrisez pas utiliser l'autre
mode est en fait nous appelons ça une
bascule
nous basculons tous les jours entre ces
deux modes mentaux et vous pourriez me
poser la question le fait-on toujours à
bon escient et la réponse est non et non
nous avons des biais cognitif et on va
faire deux exercices ensemble
le premier exercice en fait
nous allons le faire en commun nous
allons tous ensemble exprimer la couleur
dans laquelle est écrit chaque bout et
on y va
rouge bleu vert jaune bleu nuit
bah vous êtes bon là vous êtes vous
votre main d'automatique à marcher de
façon parfaite on va faire la même chose
en nommant les couleurs et on y va
bleu chaud
un stop stop stop vous avez montré quoi
qu'avec deux variables ça devient
complexe
j'aurais demandé la même chose à des
enfants de 4 ans je vous assure ce
serait pas planter parce qu'ils savent
pas lire
et maintenant on va faire un deuxième
exercice qui vous appartient qui va vous
aider dans la vie alors vous allez tous
pensé nous vous donner une petite minute
tout à l'heure vous allez penser à
chacun à une situation une situation
anodine
peu importe régulière qui soit vous
énerve
soit vous angoisse soit vous démotive et
en posant cette situation vous allez
ensuite penser à ce que j'appellerais la
version qui est derrière et je vous
donne un exemple
monfils gailleton il n'est jamais prêt à
7h45 pour partir à l'école et ça ça
m'énerve
ok bon l'émotion c'est bien sûr
l'énervement mail anti valeurs ou en
fait la version c'est parce que il est
lent et moi la lenteur ça m'énerve ok
deuxième situation mon fils vincent et
il est prêt à 7h45 et ça ça m'angoisse
il va arriver en retard
il est irrespectueux et en fait derrière
cette angoisse est au fond la notion du
respect ou alors mon fils ait jamais
pris à 7h45 voisins
c'est fini quoi oublions pas c'est un
irresponsable
qu'est-ce qui fera plus tard et donc les
responsabilités devient en fait votre
aversion et nous avons tous ainsi des
aversions dans notre vie des choses
qu'on n'aime pas ça peut être le
désordre
ça peut être la justice ni respect ça
peut être bon tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer qui nous énerve un jour où vous
angoisse et vous allez maintenant faire
l'exercice suivant
je vais vous demander à chacun voilà de
penser à une situation qui vous énerve
vous angoisse et essayer de trouver la
cause la racine si vous voulez lentilles
valeur qui est là derrière
je vous donne quelques instants et je
vais poser une deuxième question pas
après
ça va ok vous avez quelque chose
maintenant je vais vous poser une
deuxième question vous restez dans votre
émotion vous restez dans la situation et
essayer de trouver trois avantages à
cette situation
quelle question
si le trouver trois avantages oui faites
un effort
je vous laisse un peu de temps c'est
très important vous allez voir pourquoi
recueilli vous
par exemple mon fils gaëtan n'est jamais
prêt samedi est en fait un m'énerve
parce qu'il est lent au fond un avantage
c'est qu'au fond ils écoulent par
exemple je me mets sur des pistes
essayez de vous recueillir de trouver
trois avantages
ok qui en a déjà trouvé un lève le doigt
ok c'est bon merci 2 ok 3 ok maintenant
ceux qui ont déjà trouvé des avantages
vous demande vous pose la question
repensez à la chose est ce que vous
sentez mieux un petit peu beaucoup
lèvent le doigt
merci pour ceux qui se sentent un peu
mieux voilà donc car ça fait quand même
40 pour cent cinquante c'est très rapide
normalement c'est un exercice de 50
minutes mais bravo
alors qu'est ce qui se passe est en fait
je vais vous dire moi même en 94
j'étais dans mon entreprise avait 180
personnes à ce moment là tous les jours
j'aimais bien faire un tour aller voir
les gens leur parler mais j'avais vous
faites une valeur qui s'appelait
l'efficacité ok pas de problème
seulement je m'énervais où je m'angoisse
est où je me décourageait dès l'instant
où je voyais de l'inefficacité et je la
voyais à 100 mètres à la ronde
que se passait-il imaginons un chauffeur
qui lié un meuble dans un camion je
passe devant et je vais vous me mets la
fuite l'angoissent je passe devant je
vois le truc est en fait je ne fais rien
je me déstresse en continuant mon chemin
résultat zéro soit je m'énerve écoute
mon dieu ça fait trois ans que tu bosse
ici
et c'est encore comme ça que tu fais tes
ne risque de casse risque de sav service
après vente etc et donc résultats en
général c'est moins un hockey parce que
vous énervez sur quelqu'un il est
complètement tétanisés ou alors je vois
le truc non c'est pas possible que le
sytème hâtives et je remonte dans mon
bureau quoi et je passe une très
mauvaise journée et en fait comment
est-ce que ça se passe dans notre
cerveau eh bien figurez-vous que
lorsqu'on est devant une situation non
maîtrisée devant une situation complexe
et qu'on veut tout ramener à nos
certitudes à notre rigidité donc en fait
dans notre mode automatique
eh bien ça ne marche pas vous n'est ce
qui se passe c'est que lorsque face à
une situation complexe
vous restez avec votre je dirais votre
limbique presque votre mode automatique
eh bien il se passe que jiminy cricket
on en a chacun dans sa tête et jiminy
cricket va vous rappeler en fait quoi
qui a probablement une erreur
un bug et du mini cricket il se trouve
en fait dans le cortex préfrontal et se
trouve dans ce gouvernance adaptative
qui voit et c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire aujourd'hui on le sait
par irm
quand on fait le cortex préfrontal et la
seule zone du cerveau qui est relié à
toutes les autres zones et qui est un
peu un je dirais comme un poste de
pilotage qui voit tout ce qui se passe
et donc du mini krach est de notre
territoire adaptatif y va en fait nous
renseigner l'erreur et que fait-il à ce
moment là lorsqu'ils voient qu'on l'ait
vachement plantes etc on est vachement
accroché à nos croyances
eh bien il va faire il va pousser une
alarme il va pousser sur un bouton rouge
qui va en fait faire quoi qui va
atteindre l'hypothalamus
et donc nous envoyer du stress alors que
le stress à la base est pour sauver sa
peau en cas de prédateurs là le stress
est vachement utile et bien lorsque nous
restons accrochés à nos idées le stress
en fait qui se détermine par la peur
l'angoissé d'énervement où la colère et
les découragements et bien le stress est
un signal que nous avons à travailler
nous mêmes sur nos anti valeurs sûres
noah version et voilà en fait une
formule à retenir votre stress est le
fruit du stresseurs x la stresse
habilité c'est à dire qu'en fait le
stresse heures en général lorsqu'on
serait-ce voilà ils ont fait exprès
c'est pour stresser tout le monde voilà
et donc le stresse heures en général
c'est celui sur lequel ou jette notre
dévolu
lorsqu'on stress c'est toujours
quelqu'un d'autre c'est toujours une
situation
eh bien non nous avons à travailler sur
notre stress habilité sur noah version
personnelle et en fait c'est bien là
dessus parce que le foie la
multiplication lorsque vous êtes devant
un stresseurs à 100% mais que vous
n'êtes pas serait sable vous n'avez
aucun stress tant que c'est bien fois et
c'est pas plus alors on a tous été à
l'école on sait qu'un fois 020 et donc
nous avons pardon nous avons à
travailler
sonos traçabilité qui aujourd'hui dans
un monde qui change très vite nous
entraînent souvent dans la résistance de
changement et pour terminer j'ai envie
de vous montrer une image et cette image
c'est cette bouteille
cette bouteille c'est nous nous sommes
des contenants nous avons tous un
contenant dans lequel il ya des contenus
c'est à dire nos croyances nos idées nos
savoirs nos savoir-faire nos compétences
le problème c'est qu'il si nous
commençons à stresser et qu'on s'énerve
et qu'en fait ou devient très sensible à
tous mais voilà ce qu'il reste de nous
en capacité d'amélioration de notre vie
ok et donc ce que je vous apporte ce
soir en faisant ces exercices
'sur la possibilité de changer sa vision
sur les choses
est un souffle nouveau pour vous
redonner toutes vos capacités et vous en
avez tous pleins merci à tous